we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh i am really really really regretting
something i did on the show
two weeks ago now
someone said david if you had to leave
the country where would you go i have no
plan to leave the country
i don't think it's going to be necessary
to leave the country but i answered the
question anyway and i said well i could
go back to argentina any time because i
was born there so i could i can go any
time um as a jewish individual i could
go to israel at any time
i'm working on getting european
citizenship through my grandfather who
fled poland before but i'm not planning
to do any okay
the number of messages i have received
now from people saying david i'm
canceling my membership because i don't
want to be with someone who's going to
abandon us if the going gets stuff all
these different things i regret even
talking about it and now this is sort of
the height of it
this caller said david
you planning to leave
makes you seem
like the unpatriotic jew who will take
his capital and leave with no loyalty
we've gotten to the anti-semitic tropes
part
of the leaving the country timeline take
a listen to this
hey
dave my name is jeff and i'm calling
about your recent segments reference you
leaving the united states if things go
authoritarian
that raises a couple of concerns i think
that we're born out in alex jones's
response to those videos
the first concern is is that it
reinforces the trope the jews aren't
really patriotic or good citizens in
here you know you're saying if things
get bad enough you'll leave
uh second uh concern is that promotes a
trope that
you know jews are a global set who will
pick up their capital and split look for
better markets the first sort of trouble
i'm saying this is a guy who by right
may go to israel or may go to spain
but i won't go to either one of those
places except and only if i'm a tourist
if things get bad here it's only because
we let them get back
guys
i'm not leaving
in a true dystopia the likes of which i
was imagining when i answered the
question we would all be looking to
leave there wouldn't be any more tourism
it would be an emergency we would all be
looking for safe haven me being jewish
wouldn't change that this was a question
asked by the audience if you were to
leave because things got so bad where
would you go and it's true if i left i'm
not going to go to thailand or norway
where i both don't speak the language
and have no way to actually go to
legally if i left i would be more likely
to go to argentina because i was born
there or to israel
for legal reasons but i'm not planning
on leaving and it was clearly a very big
mistake to even entertain the question
what a disaster
on today's bonus show we will talk about
a massive winter storm coming that will
stretch 2 000 miles
it is going to hit areas that don't
typically have winter storms and are
much less prepared
and have disastrous infrastructure are
we looking at another potential
uh
episode
of what happened in texas with
electricity in a bunch of states because
this storm is so widespread and if so
what are republicans going to say about
infrastructure hope it doesn't happen
we'll talk about it on today's bonus
show we will also talk about the big
headline among many on the right that
for the first time ever america's
national debt has surpassed 30 trillion
dollars what does it actually mean
without hyperbole we will talk about it
and lastly
their jury deliberations have started in
the roy moore defamation case you might
have we talked about this case a long
time ago
you might have forgotten about it
uh jury deliberations have started and
we're going to talk about what's at
stake there all of those stories and
more i am told
uh on today's bonus show
we will be
i'm i'm told there's something going on
for my birthday on today's bonus show i
don't know what it is i'm as curious as
you are
join it
join pacman.com get instant access and
we will see you on the bonus show or
otherwise tomorrow